depuis hier après midi beaucoup beaucoup
de marioupol cette ville du sud
stratégique
lourdement pilonné ces derniers jours et
il ya cette question de l'hôpital
pédiatrique et de cette maternité qui
qui fait débat la question a été posée à
sergueï lavrov il ya premier ministre
espagnol qui a réagi qui a appuyé les
propos du président vaut l'oni 20 cm ce
qui ils parlent de crime de guerre je
rappelle que officiellement il est trois
personnes qui ont perdu la vie il ya
dansé dans ces bâtiments dont un enfant
nous on n'a pas pu vérifier ce qui était
ce qui s'y était passé oui il ya même le
premier ministre britannique qui s'est
empressé de réagir hier soir je crois
qu'il faut rester extrêmement prudent
effectivement parce que nos équipes
france 24 sur le terrain n'a pas pu
vérifier ce qui s'est effectivement
passé dans cet hôpital de marioupol hier
ce qui est très clair c'est qu'il ya
deux versions qui sont absolument
opposées d'un côté à vous avez les
ukrainiens qui disent les russes ont
sciemment bombardé une maternité avec
des civils des enfants des femmes en
train d'accoucher et de l'autre des
russes qui disent absolument pas le
bâtiment était totalement vide est
occupé par des forces l'ukrainienne en
tout cas marioupol ce qu'on peut dire ce
matin c'est que la situation est on ne
peut plus critique dans cette ville vous
savez que 450 mille personnes sont en ce
moment coincé dans cette ville qui est
en état de siège vous la voyez cette
ville dans les uns des enjeux dit cette
réunion tuatapere les faire aller faire
sortir de la ville c'est exactement ce
qu'a dit tout à fait demi trop cool et
bat en substance j'étais venu là pour
trouver une solution pour ces couloirs
humanitaires et en particulier pour
mario pole parce qu'il le sait la
situation là bas est urgente et
apocalyptique c'est ce que disait hier
la croix rouge il est va revenir les
mains vides mais trop collé bas parce
que les russes n'ont pas dit oui un
couloir humanitaire pour mario paul on a
même eu des informations ce matin disant
qu'un convoi humanitaire qui faisait
route vers marioupol et bien a été forcé
de faire demi-tour donc les russes n'ont
très clairement pas l'intention
d'évacuer marioupol malgré ce qu'ils
disent et malgré les annonces de
couloirs humanitaires entre guillemets